foreign
s have always been sure my basic needs
were met but growing up I felt like I
was a referee in their relationship
unfortunately I was giving the diagnosis
of block two and with this diagnosis I
feel like this is just a slap in the
face that I yet again have to do another
hard thing and it felt really lonely
what's up this is John with the Dr John
deloney's show
and I guess I'm going through puberty
because I think my voice just cracked
my dad said it was going to happen at
some point and look at here kids I'm in
my 40s and it finally turned man so good
hey
um this is the greatest mental health in
marriage and parenting podcast ever
so I want you to have good relationships
man good interactions with real humans
in the real world so we set this show up
to just sit with one another walk
alongside each other during the mess
that is it is our lives and figure out
the next right thing to do and so I'm so
grateful for everybody who trusts us and
who calls in and my promises I'm gonna
tell you the truth and I'm gonna be here
with you so give us a buzz
1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask and do our best to figure out what
comes next hey before we get going
Ben
you are now in on a very short list a
list of one of friends of mine actually
you're number two number two my friend
Katie one time you're my second friend
who had an interaction with a semi and
you lived to tell the tale it was a bad
interaction too yeah it wasn't it wasn't
like we're getting coffee like this is
Jesus Take the Wheel yeah what happened
so uh I was just minding my own business
driving on 65. as a guy in a small
compound Pacific hybrid hybrid would do
there you go yeah uh this 18 wheeler
merges into my lane without looking or
telling that I'm in the lane currently
uh so he just clipped me with his bumper
I went spinning about three times landed
in the ditch and uh
record right round yeah and then you
just got up danced Jesus Took the Wheel
for real I mean honestly and my our
Texas listeners are like well told you
that's what you get for driving a hybrid
she get a bigger hey I'm glad you're all
right that's good that would have been
sad it would have been but I'm not gonna
lie
and this goes for everybody working on
the show if one of y'all has a run with
a semi and you don't win and I will use
it in some sort of talk in some
meaningful moment and I'll make a career
out of it so just know stay alive for
the show stay alive for the show uh no
I'm I'm happy that you're um well man
all right good thank you hey the y'all
had a
y'all have had it this month huh
it's time for this year to be over for
the for the The Hill Family yes a lot of
stuff going on yeah dude 23 is going to
be your year in the year of the dump
button yes yes all right let's go to CR
inside joke let's go to Chrissy and and
we're all inside and y'all still don't
get it haha let's go to Chrissy in
Boston what's up Chrissy
Hi how are you good how are you
how are you oh I'm I'm good I can't
believe I'm talking to you I was just
thinking I can't believe I'm talking to
you that's so good
I first want to say thank you for all
that you do I listened to your show
regularly and has really helped me you
are thank you for being kind
um it's so easy for me to get off the
air and I don't really talk to anybody
I'm like staring at a camera right now
just pretending I'm looking at you and
um it's often easy to wonder like what
am I doing with my life and so thank you
so much for your kindness I'm grateful
of my parents
um
and to give you some context um
I'm gonna set this Grenade on the coffee
table and I'm gonna pull it down and
they're all gonna sit down and watch it
yeah so uh what does that mean tell me
what that means yeah so um me and my
husband wanted to start to grow our
family and unfortunately I was giving
the diagnosis of block two
uh y'all starting IVF
yeah we're starting our IVF Journey so
sorry if I have tears
um and um I'm so thankful for science
but I'm I'm really angry
um but this is another thing that I have
to do by myself in life
um my parents have always been sure my
basic needs were met but growing up I
felt like I was a referee in their
relationship with their arguments which
most of them were about my mother being
irresponsible with money or my dad being
drunk
um I've worked really hard to have a
good self-esteem and confidence about
myself I'm really good with money I
think before I speak I'm a good listener
and lastly if you need a friend I try to
be the person who others can call on I
don't ask for much in life but I've
always wanted to be a mom
and with this diagnosis I feel like this
is just a slap in the face that after
being such a caregiver during my
childhood that I yet again have to do
another hard thing and it feels so
I felt really lonely yeah
I'm sorry
thank you
um
who's walking with you in this season
who's walking with me
who have you told what you just told me
who have you already told that to beside
your husband
um my therapist
okay so you got to rent a friend who's
like a person in your life
um
I have I have friends um hold on hold on
hold on hold on who have you told what
you just told me
I'm going through IVF but not all the
um I guess all of those things there you
go
so
you have said like it just I want you to
go back and hit like the 15 second back
button a few times when you first hear
this call okay in the very in your
opening sentences you said things like I
feel and I think and I've tried
that is that is the language of somebody
who was responsible who was the
irresponsible adult in her household
that is the language of somebody who
grew up with an addict
an erratic parent somebody who grew up
in chaos
and the reason that's the language of
somebody who grew up in chaos is you
don't know what it even feels like to be
whole or more importantly to trust
yourself and let me change your language
for you because I can tell you within 30
seconds of hearing from you
you did
and you are not you think and you feel
you are a world-class friend
you're a world-class daughter and you're
gonna be a
incredible mom
okay
yep that all of that starts with you
trusting yourself and that's something
you're gonna have to practice because
you've never
you've never been able to do it the
trust you had in yourself was that you
could make sure everybody was okay so
you could play the game so you could
survive Fair
yeah yeah
and you shouldn't have to be going
through this alone
but at this point this is where I'm
gonna this is hard language I know
you have to choose to not be lonely
anymore
which means you have to open yourself up
to potentially being hurt really bad
again
by telling your friends I'm heartbroken
and I'm sad I'm scared and one of them
is going to say something stupid
one of them's gonna hurt your feelings
one of them is going to say something
dumb what I'm gonna be like oh yeah well
my journey was and you're gonna be like
how about you take your journey and
shove it up right it doesn't matter
and they're going to screw it up and
you're gonna have to continue to be
vulnerable and choose to not be lonely
is that fair
yeah no that that's definitely fair I
definitely
um struggle with
um I always feel like when I'm talking
with friends with something going on
with my like it feels like I'm overly
asserting myself or or or putting my
problems onto others that's because the
people who were by Design supposed to
teach you how to carry problems
gave you theirs
yeah
as a young kid you've heard my bricks in
the backpack instead of parents walking
alongside their children and holding
their bricks with them and teaching them
the weight and how heavy things are age
appropriately your parents handed you
all their cinder blocks and said here
kid you carry this
and so now basic I need help basic will
you just cry with me basic hey will you
bring chips and queso over because I
don't want to get out of bed
um that feels like a burden
instead of just life
yeah you know what I mean
no yeah no that that makes perfect can I
say something provocative
yeah I don't think you're mad at your
parents
I think you're mad at your body
that too
I think they're the easy Target because
they were they were so
um they did such a bad job with you
um and it's okay to be really mad at
your body
the one thing man can I just have this
one thing God can I just have one thing
yeah it feels like I was gonna get like
something you know I feel like I've been
a good person and
I don't know I feel like I've done a lot
of my I've done a lot of heart stuff in
my life and I just want it the one thing
I've always wanted to be easy yeah and
it's not and oh and you see you see
every family member getting somebody
knocked up and you see every 16 year old
with unwanted right you see it all over
the place right oh yeah and it just yeah
there's gasoline on that fire
yeah and it just feels like why me yes
and so let me tell you the question
why me
is a question that doesn't have an
answer
but it's an invitation to all sorts of
mental and spiritual and physical
um dysregulation
okay
of all the I'll tell people all day long
I'll tell you be super pissed at your
body be upset I have a friend who really
really struggled with infertility and
she was like I didn't have a period
every month of my freaking life
since I was 11 until now to not be like
it was she's a she was cracking me up
and we were both like laughs crying
together
um like be upset at the whole thing
you have been living in a world where
he
oh man
I'm gonna say it this way you've been
living in a world where you woke up and
the score was already a hundred to zero
and you were losing
right and so you thought I can put 500
points in this bucket and it will
balance out cosmically and there's few
things more terrifying than realizing
that nature and the world don't work
that way
that instead of stacking the deck with
kindness and generosity and well-being
and peace making not peacekeeping
peacemaking because it's just right and
because it it gives us a simpler
day-to-day present
it's easy to start stacking the deck
thinking that it's gonna there's gonna
be an Roi on it for us it's going to pay
us back someday
yeah right and it's just not how it
works and that's devastating when we
realize that
so what I would tell you is don't don't
spin the energy the one thing I'm going
to tell you feel your feelings man be
upset be raged out be angry be
frustrated weep bitterly
yeah put to bed the question why me
instead say
why me or not not why me instead ask
yourself what am I gonna do next
what am I gonna do next
because it is I shouldn't even like um I
guess I I'm just so
upset with my
hair I mean I I know I have to separate
the two
um my being mad at my body but I I guess
I don't understand or I'm I'm struggling
with but now that I'm starting this
journey that these feelings about my
parents have like risen to the top like
it like it's keeping me up at night like
just thinking about the chaos that I was
raised in and how because it's not fair
it's not fair
yeah because you want this so badly and
you know what kind of parent you're
gonna be and they just got it it fell
from the sky for them and they they were
flipping about it and they abused it
yeah and every second you spend thinking
about them
is a choice to be less joyful in your
present
they're not worth your your time they're
not worth the space in your soul
they're not worth even considering in
the same thought pattern as this future
baby you're gonna hold one day
yeah they're just it's not
and here's your body's trying to keep
you safe because you weren't for a long
time
and so when things got scary and things
got hard and things got frightening
we went back to the old ways the old
lessons that we had learned
and you've been a parent since you were
very very young
yeah and now it's time to let the little
kid off the hook she needs to be done
being a parent now
right okay yeah yeah so you hear me say
this all the time it's one of the most
therapeutic exercises in the the science
literature Bears it out but more
importantly just the people that I
interact with on a daily basis
have you sat down and written that
letter to your parents yet that you'll
never give them
you need you need to do that and it's
probably going to be three different
letters
and one of them will be
how dare you I can't believe what
happened
the second one will be
it's not all bad here's what also what
you gave me
because of you here's who I am today
and the third one is
here's what you missed and here's what
you're gonna miss
because me Chrissy from Boston freaking
Massachusetts
spending some time with some at some
Harvard bars all right of course best
city hey
um it's a close second to Houston but uh
Chrissy from Boston drinking a laga
listen
our sports teams do always win though
just saying I mean you'll finish last
place in the Astros in the World Series
right now but it's cool we can talk
about that later
hey the Astros beat the Yankees can we
agree on that that was good that was
good
um
hey we're moving on
now you got a new Journey now it's about
okay cool
um my body didn't line up how I thought
I'm gonna grieve it I thought this
picture was gonna look like this and it
didn't
I'm gonna be heartbroken for a season
and then
I'm gonna take care of myself because
I'm a person who takes care of my body
and I'm gonna eat right and I'm gonna
exercise and my husband and I are gonna
have tons of fun practicing this thing
that we're doing because it's awesome
and I'm gonna trust my doctors and can I
give you one piece of wisdom
um on the IVF Journey
of course have a Finish Line in mind
before you go down that road
here's how much money we're going to
spend we're going to try this many times
there's so many eggs we're going to
fertilize this is this is our plan and
we don't go past it without
several months of hard thinking and
prayer time if you're a person of faith
and wisdom seeking because it can become
its own nightmarish journey and you're
gonna wake up and be 200 Grand in the
hole and it's gonna be a mess
yes okay yeah and if the day comes
um
one of the ways I keep myself well is
um I always always am out on the
optimistic side of things things could
turn out really really great and I
always hold very Loosely they might not
yeah they might not
and so make peace in your heart make
peace inside make peace with your
husband make peace with your friends and
your community
that motherhood may look different
may look different I don't think I don't
think it is I think the ivf's gonna work
I do I don't know why maybe I'm just
putting it out in the universe but I
think I think it's going to work
um but if it doesn't
it won't be because you did something
wrong
or didn't do it do enough good to
balance out the other side of the Ledger
and it won't be because your parents
were extra extra me
sometimes things just are
sometimes things just are
don't we own what is we acknowledge
reality and then we ask ourselves that
terrifying question what are we going to
do next hang on the line my friend
um I'm gonna send you a couple things
now what I'm gonna send you on your past
change your future read that book
um let's talk about healing from trauma
and it's got some some waste it's gonna
walk you through the letter writing and
I'm going to send you questions for
humans couples Edition I want you and
your husband to stay connected during
your IVF Journey Don't let the
um don't let the metrics and the numbers
and the holding your breath pull you all
apart y'all stay connected as you can
okay thank you so much for being brave
and for walking through your journey
with us um
when you get pregnant let us know let us
be the second to know
and we'll tell the world we'll be right
back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement in MLS ID 1591 in MLS
consumeraccess.org Equal Housing lender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and not available in all
states or locations
all right we're back let's go to Andrew
in Atlanta Georgia home of the Braves at
lost what's up Andrew
hey Dr John how are you doing just
taking my digs in before the Astros uh
they're not looking great right now so
what's up man
weird one so
so you've got hey you called the right
show you called the right show right
so um back in September we went on a
Disney trip with the whole family it was
a paid for Thing by my mother-in-law oh
gosh I'll give you a couple red flags we
were all staying in the same Airbnb
you all have kids
yes okay there were two two or mine and
my wife's and the other two are my
sister-in-laws
um and they're all between the ages of
four and seven
so what could possibly go wrong Awesome
everything uh
the other part of the trip was they
wanted us all to ride together down
which my wife refused she's like no
we're driving separate hey you married
well okay continue
yeah she's pretty smart
um
so we get down there and everything's
kind of going okay
um and then we have an issue one night
um my sister-in-law loves to go from
zero to 100 for nothing like absolutely
nothing I'm not sure scream at my
mother-in-law over stupid stuff at
Christmas you know we're trying to have
a nice time and we're getting screened
at because the potatoes weren't the way
she wanted or whatever right
um it's just a normal thing to watch and
it's um you know I've kept my mouth shut
been married for eight years kept my
mouth shut right
um my wife and her go back and forth
over a toy of all things which my wife
was just trying to say we need to find
you know our son's version of this
because he had you know her son's
version of that and she was like scream
bloody murder kids were done they wanted
to go home my wife was done she wanted
to go home I told myself just wait calm
down high tension right trying to be The
Optimist High attention let's just calm
down if she does it again let me handle
it like she's a bully she won't let you
talk anything say anything you know when
you're trying to express whatever it is
you're trying to say in the moment like
let me deal with it I've been dealing
with those for my whole life I've got
this
well the next evening she starts it
again but she's starting to bad mouth my
wife in front of my kids while we're at
the pool like we're in the pool there's
a pool in the back of the Airbnb they're
all sitting on the patio and um she
starts saying something so I just looked
at her and I said I wouldn't say
anything
and she just looked across the patio at
me and she was like excuse me
and I was like I wouldn't I wouldn't say
anything you know
just telling you I wouldn't start she's
like she's like I wouldn't start I was
like do you want to do this right now
she said yeah I want to do this right
now so I call her a bully
and she lost it she absolutely lost it
screaming out there all kinds of
obscenities freaking the Freak Out the
kids are all stunned they're all in the
pool they're all stunned and you know
she storms in
and I'm just like okay that was a
interesting reaction
well her six foot four 350 to 400 pound
boyfriend steps out of the house oh yeah
yeah so I'm sitting in the corner of the
patio there's a table in front of me and
now he is pulling up a chair right in
front of me dude this is when you sweep
the leg did you not watch Karate Kid One
well he was sitting he was a chair I was
in a chair that's fair I'm all about
de-escalating you know and but he comes
up he gets right in my face and he says
you want to see a bully
and I burst out laughing I burst out
laughing I look over at my mother-in-law
and I'm like is this guy kidding like
are we serious uh by now my wife had
re-entered you know the patio and um she
was coming to get the kids after she was
screaming and she saw what was going on
she tried to
um you know put herself between me and
him and kind of push him back and he
stood up and she's telling him the other
way you know we're not scared of you
we're leaving get out of our way
um she pushes the table out of the way
and when she does that he reaches out
and pulls true out from under me
um I stand up but he puts me in a
headlock
so I'm still sitting there trying to
de-escalate
um I'm waiting to see what happens it's
not a tight headlock so I don't feel
scared or intimidated or anything at the
moment yet
and uh finally he lets me go we pack all
of our stuff we go get her on hotel we
leave the house okay you fast forward me
two right now how can I help you right
now so right now so after that happens
uh the in-laws
sent my wife says crazy text about how
she needs to deal with her hatred and
her heart and they never even got to
thank you for the trip and all this
stuff this is the night this all
happened that we got in the hotel sure
um and uh Bermuda right now that can
help you right now
so you know we have not communicated
with them since this happened absolutely
um
everybody's opted out
right they chose the other side they
went to Disney and had fun the next day
with this guy that handled their
son-in-law
um so going into the holidays my you
know hey we already know that's not
happening
um so hey how do we communicate to our
kids like when they start asking hey
when are we going to their house and
stuff like hey that's that's not
happening
um and B what's our best foot forward
and I mean they've opted out but should
we say something like hey you were wrong
for this or should we just let it go no
I mean okay so
foreign
number one I mean the way you told the
story you had some bravado you waltzed
in I I've been handling this my whole
life
I got this and then you didn't
and so part of me you invited it in
you entered into a conflict that wasn't
yours between two sisters
and it ended poorly okay and so I think
there's something to be learned about if
you're gonna say you better recognize
then you might get recognized right and
then the second thing is
it went sideways and you all left you
should have left
and it's devastating when we can't you
can't talk something out right it's
devastating when
um parents don't say hey that is
unacceptable and
your in-laws are clearly
trying to prop up a picture of a happy
family
and they're willing to put thousands and
thousands of dollars towards this
picture it's a myth it's a fantasy
for whatever reason my guess is they
know what a train wreck your
sister-in-law is
they probably have problems with you and
they're trying to recreate a Norman
Rockwell painting in real life and it's
not real and so when somebody walks out
of the picture regardless of why they
left they are the bad guy because they
left the picture
and so the next day everybody woke up
the sun came up and you all were the
ones that were gone so y'all are the
easy bad guys okay here's why that
doesn't matter
y'all left you did the right thing
I would not have talked to them since
then I would have let them if they
choose to re-engage us great but
we put our boundaries up and we're out
and when the kids ask
you say remember Aunt so and so when she
was screaming and yelling I remember
when her big boyfriend
um put his hands on Dad we only go
places where it's safe for the whole
family and so we're not going to go
there
that's it that is it and we're not gonna
we don't have to have a bunch of other
conversations my promise to you is the
kids are going to think way less of this
than you all are
and my also promise is for your wife
this isn't this is the world she grew up
in
and so she's probably been going back
and saying she's sorry and fixing the
the
family dysregulation for a long time and
it's easier to walk out in the heat of a
moment but as time goes on it's like
well you know and dad was and mom was
sister was really and so that's probably
been her whole life
and so you are gonna have to decide to
hold firm on this and choose safety and
choose joy and choose laughter right
holidays are too short man they're too
precious
I I guess here's what I'm struggling
with one
I mean you stepped into it and it
happened
two I don't know
I don't know what you're lamenting or
sad about or did you did you you took a
stand
and nobody stood with you I guess is the
challenge here but I don't know what
you're upset about it seems like it's
all played out perfectly you don't have
to be around these in-laws who aren't
seeing the world clearly and you don't
have to be around an unsafe
sister-in-law and her boyfriend like I
don't know what you're upset about
well you know there's a
you know reconciliation and you know
like you can't right I'm not you cannot
reconcile with people who don't want to
be reconciled with
so we should wait for them to come
around and realize they were kind of
being stupid in the in the moment rather
than point out to them don't put yeah
what last time you pointed out things
how did that end it ended you in the
armpit of a 400 pound man
all right like they have no interest in
seeing
anything other than their perspective
yes you pointing this things out will
not help the situation at all
you choosing
to not carry their bricks around you
choosing to find joy
you choosing to make the best of a
holiday season maybe the first one in
eight years it's going to be one of
peace and not anger and not accelerated
heart rates and you dancing around and
trying not to set off sister-in-law and
trying to make sure your wife is uh
maybe for the first time
y'all just get a hotel with a pool and
let your kids Remember the Time Santa
showed up at the hotel and just have a
good three-day weekend you know what I
mean reimagine the whole thing and and
and have that be something beautiful and
fun not lamenting
got it does that make sense
yeah it is an utter waste of your time
to try to come up with the right word I
mean literally think through us through
is there something you're gonna say your
sister-in-law is going to be like no way
I never thought of that
thanks Andrew like no it's never gonna
happen you know what I mean or like uh
her giant boyfriend is gonna be like hey
man listen when you call my girlfriend a
bully
you're right she's rude and I'm we're
going to counseling is that gonna happen
no it's not gonna happen he did what
he's what boyfriends do right and and so
on so on down the line it's here's what
it it feels disorienting because you
feel powerless you can't solve this
problem and as you said at the very
beginning of the call you have a history
of solving these type of problems of
waiting in being the calm person in the
storm saying the right thing and
everyone's like you're right and this is
one you can't solve and so that means
you have to dust your sandals off as the
great Jay-Z says brush your shoulders
off and walk on man
right
you don't sound like you believe me well
no so I just the other thing to you know
my wife my wife sees a therapist every
week and uh has been unpacking this too
and you know there's a co-dependent
relationship there that she recognizes
and she's with her mom and she's you
know been dissecting that but
you know the part part of the hard thing
too is like you know she feels sometimes
like when she leaves work she wants to
call her mom she wants to absolutely
absolutely it's not out of hey I have
joy in this it's out of that
relationship they have it's no it's it's
a codependency in its in its root form
is an addiction it's a love addiction as
the great PM Melody says
she's addicted to the chemicals she gets
when she creates a fantasy and tries to
uphold her side of it
and occasionally her mom is really kind
and occasionally her mom is funny and
tells her a hilarious story and then she
falls under the illusion that's my real
mom there she is I just need to do more
of this so that real mom stays out more
and then real mom actually shows up and
real mom is dysfunctional and real mom
is predatory and real mom uses your wife
as a prop in her play
all the while your daughter's asking
herself the same question she's been
asking since she was a little girl what
is it what's so bad about me what's
wrong with me
that mommy won't fully connect with me
and that's not a question kids need to
ask that's the adult question
and so yes it's totally natural for your
wife to just want to pick up the phone
and call her mom
totally natural
totally natural for your wife to be
heartbroken and weep over the holidays
season this year
totally normal that's just grief the gap
between what we wanted and what we hoped
for and what reality gave us
that's where y'all are and then you have
to ask yourself like many callers on
this show like I have to ask myself
what are we gonna do next are we gonna
sit and wallow in this
or are we going to choose Joy
are we going to construct something new
that's going to be fun and we're going
to give our kids a wild great time we
get to pick we get to pick
one like for me at my house we're gonna
choose Joy every single time
sorry man
brush your shoulders off brother move on
to the next
we'll be right back
deloney here and I've got a word from
this episode's sponsor betterhelp let's
all be honest life would be way easier
if it came with a user manual marriage
parenting work making friends especially
as adults but this is the truth my
friends there's no step-by-step guide
you have to take ownership of your life
and when it feels like too much or you
feel stuck or overwhelmed it's too easy
to get lost in the anxiety black hole
I've been there but you can learn to
navigate this beautiful chaos we call
life in a healthy way therapy gives you
the tools to do just that and that's why
I love better help better help is online
therapy that offers video phone even
live chat sessions with your therapist
there's no waiting rooms no traffic no
endlessly searching for the right
therapist that happens to not take your
insurance listen better help us
connected more than three million people
with licensed therapists and they can
match you with a therapist under 48
hours so don't settle for feeling stuck
visit betterhelp.com com deloney today
to learn more and get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp.com deloney
all right we are back in
is there like do we have some theme
music
[Music]
the new facts are your friends segments
it's a couple of days after Thanksgiving
and some of you are still sitting there
in shock that you just experienced the
holiday season that you experienced
the uh Thanksgiving at your in-laws
house or at your parents house or you
just stared at your significant other
and thought this is my life this is this
is my life or your kids said that thing
Thanksgiving dinner and you thought well
I'm gonna go bury myself in the backyard
um
or
you were at your grandma's house
and your son came out and you asked him
hey uh did you change your underwear
after you just took your shower
and he said something like I haven't
changed it in four days why would I
change it now and you think I don't like
to I don't I don't like the holidays
here we are
now
today's facts of your friends is gonna
be around a segment I mean around
something I get asked all the time
direct messages people email into the
show
it's the idea of choosing guilt over
resentment
you just left Thanksgiving and let's be
honest for many of you for millions of
you it was awesome it was a great time
with friends it was a great time with
family it was good
some of you just took a dive and when
somebody started talking politics did
you vote who'd you vote for I you were
just like all right I'm gonna just Jesus
take the wheel and others of you had a
rough go of it it was a long ride in the
car on the way there it was a long run
on the way back you didn't sleep you
can't go to the bathroom in other
people's homes whatever the thing was
right
and now you're already making plans for
what Christmas is going to look like the
Christmas holidays the New Year's
holidays we're gonna go somewhere we're
gonna not go anywhere who's coming to
our house
what are we gonna buy Grandma already
buys all this stuff mom and dad buy it
sister's gonna
what are we gonna do we're gonna choose
guilt over resentment all right so I'll
tell you this fact to your friends guilt
over resentment here's what it looks
like all right guilt I took some notes
Here
guilt is the frustration or anger that I
feel
when I violate my own core values
core values are wrong if they're dumb
like one of my core values used to be I
will make sure everybody else is is okay
before me
and what that often meant was I ended up
agreeing to conversations about stupid
stuff that I didn't care about or that I
abjectly disagreed with
um
my one of my uh core values used to be
nobody's gonna disrespect me and so I
spent a whole bunch of useless energy
trying to make sure everybody else
recognized how important I was and how
good I was and how smart I was and how
accomplished I was complete not a waste
of time
and if I didn't get my hey did you hear
that I got another degree or I won this
leadership award here I got into Harvard
but whatever the thing was I'd feel
guilty about it I should have told him I
shouldn't have said that I said too much
oh my goodness Guild kill guilt can also
be a value that's really important I
stole something and I feel guilty about
it I swore at my kid and I I yelled at
my kid and I feel guilty about that
that's not who I want to be it's not who
I am and I did that thing
um I snapped at my wife I showed up late
to work again like I feel guilty it
violates a core value here right so
guilt is when you do something that
violates your core value feel guilty
about it
Court one of your core values
resentment on the other hand is the
jealousy I feel when someone has power
over me that I've even either conceded I
gave it away to him or they took it from
me because they're in a position of
power they've got bigger muscles than me
they're stronger than me I'm staying in
their house
they're paying my car insurance they
helped out with my down payment on my
house and they've been holding over my
head for 10 years whatever the thing is
Right resentment is about jealousy brene
Brown has an incredible discussion about
this if you want to go further down the
rabbit hole in this
um that we all thought resentment was
about rage was about anger and actually
it's about jealousy
that you have that kind of power over me
and here's the deal guilt is healthy I
think guilt is healthy I think it's an
evolutionary
um emotion right it's important for our
bodies to feel guilty when we violate
core values they're going to ultimately
separate us from our Our Gang from our
people from our tribe from our community
from our spouses from our kids it's
important that our body has a reaction
to that so we stop the behavior and then
we do the necessary things we ask for
forgiveness we say we're sorry we bridge
the gap or we put up boundaries whatever
we got to do to become right with
ourselves and right with our community
again guilt I think on the whole is good
when you put guilt in your backpack and
you choose to carry it you go from I did
a dumb thing to I am a dumb thing right
that's shame
guilt in and of itself is good
resentment
is not
resentment is the death of almost every
relationship
resentment is Ash after a fire
right
um
choosing guilt over resentment is a
powerful way to reclaim your life
when somebody challenges your boundaries
you're going to be uncomfortable you're
going to get frustrated you're going to
get annoyed I said we're not spending
more than a hundred dollars on all of
Christmas gifts and you went and bought
a 500 Xbox for one kid and Nike shoes
for another kid
man somebody challenged your boundaries
they ran right over them to see if
they're if they were true they're gonna
hold
and you take the gifts and you put them
back in the package and you set them on
the counter and say we are not taking
these gifts
thank you for
um loving our kids but we all agreed
we're not doing this for our kids
they've got enough stuff at the house
um and we agreed on that you're gonna
feel so guilty and they're gonna make
you feel guilty
they're gonna make you feel guilty
that's okay
the alternative is resentment taking
them the whole way home seething
they got more power over my kids than I
do
they've got more influence and sway
because I said nothing I just gave it
away or I had to take this because I
wasn't safe
it's resentment
it's Ash
and so here let's bring this home really
close let's take husbands and wives
husband comes in and says hey every
Christmas we're going to Grandma's house
and you spouse wife you know that at
Grandma's house you always end up in the
kitchen with the four other women
and they're always talking about how
much their husbands are lame and you
actually like yours
in one year you spoke up and it's like I
actually like him and everybody laughed
at you rolled their eyes
somebody asked you why your jeans were
so small
they made fun of your shirt
they asked you oh did you start going to
Great Clips for your hair again they
just you're tired of it
they ask you why you let your kids talk
that way
why they don't have such some app on
their phone and you say we don't do
phones and like oh I got your kid the
new iPhone
you're just done you're done
and here's what you can do
you can sit down with your husband well
in advance and say listen
this year
I don't want to miss the holidays again
I show up in body but I miss him in
spirit I'm not the mom I want to be I'm
not the wife I want to be I'm not the me
I want to be
and so I'm asking you to join me in
recreating a new holiday memory and
we'll let our families know that the
show we're not going to travel this year
we're going to do things our Christmas
at home
and the moment you say those words
you're going to feel guilty because you
know your husband likes going home
because he gets to go hunting with the
guys they all go out they all hang out
and have a good time whatever and he's
not stuck at home doing bad times doing
morning times listening to all the
reasons he's a failure
you're gonna feel guilty
and that's better than yet again getting
in the car seething the whole week
before
seething the whole way there snapping at
your little ones being cold being
frustrated turning the music up a little
bit louder turning your headphones up a
little bit louder and when he reaches
over to connect with you you rip one of
the headphones out you go what what it's
not about him that's you
that's the jealousy
somebody else has control over your life
so this year
whenever you start to think I don't want
to do this I don't want to go I don't
want to be a part of this
think about choosing guilt over
resentment
choose feeling guilty and having
boundaries choose feeling guilty and
having peace choose feeling guilty
over resentment anger rage jealousy
frustration
because your kids are going to look back
and remember not what you said but how
you made them feel as the old quote goes
and they're going to remember whether
the holidays were a season of warmth
a season of laughter and joy or a season
of great tension
and they are going to make up their own
stories as to why it was tense and most
kids most of the time put them at the
center of that story that they were
doing something wrong
husbands and wives do it to each other
too
so let's choose honesty let's choose
openness
let's choose boundaries let's choose
what if we
what if we designed
the perfect Christmas and we reverse
engineered it and said how close can we
get to that
not we have to go do these five things
we have to spend this much money we have
to travel this far
what if we didn't do that this time
what if we said here's what would be the
best holidays for us this season let's
reverse engineer and build that and it
might include family and it might not
this year and that's okay you still love
them still love them
but not this year this year we're gonna
lay low we're gonna hang out we're gonna
do us stuff
we're gonna go just play in a hotel pool
kids will think that's more fun than an
Xbox anyway
choose guilt over resentment
Kelly does that cover it
sounds good love it
all right good that's facts of your
friends volume what
111. we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book oh in
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right we are back as we wrap up
today's show hey start planning now for
what Christmas is going to look like you
got about a month
don't just let it show up and hit you in
the mouth plan for it all of it and the
song of the day listen new uh Dr John
deloney's show tradition if somebody
gets in a car wreck and nearly dies
the song of the day is Carrie
Underwood's Jesus Take the Wheel Ben
we're glad you're still with us
everybody else in the booth no more
wrecks no more wrecks drive carefully
especially those with hybrids be safe
she was driving last Friday on the way
to Cincinnati on a snow white Christmas
Eve going home to see her mama and her
daddy with her baby in the back seat
50 miles to go and she was running low
on faith and gasoline my car doesn't run
on faith I think that's the new hybrid
it'd be a law it's been a long hard year
she had a lot on her mind and she didn't
pay attention she was going way too fast
before she knew it she was spinning on a
thin black sheet of glass or in Ben's
case
because of emerging semi
she saw both their lives flushed before
her eyes she didn't even have time to
cry she was so scared she threw her
hands up in the air
and she didn't wave him around like she
just didn't care
she said Jesus Take the Wheel take it
from my hands because I can't do this on
my own I'm Letting Go
Jesus Take the Wheel we'll see you soon
[Music]